THE NAVY SAYS THE NEW CASES WILL
NOT AFFECT OPERATIONS ON THESE
THOUSAND VET HOSPITAL SHIPS.
>> Ed: IN THE MEANTIME,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS ACROSS AMERICA
ARE STRUGGLING TO GET THE
CRITICAL PROTECTIVE GEAR THEY
NEED IT.
OUR GUEST JUMPED INTO ACTION
WHEN SHE SAW FIRSTHAND HOW HARD
IT WAS TO GET A HOLD OF SOME OF
THESE CRUCIAL MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
CONGRESSMAN, WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING IN.
TALK ABOUT SOME AREAS WHERE THIS
PROTECTIVE GEAR HAS NOW COME IN.
IT APPEARS THAT OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINE ARE
GETTING WHAT THEY NEED IT BUT IT
TAKES A LOT OF WORK AS YOU KNOW
FIRSTHAND.
>> YEAH, AND IT’S PRETTY SPOTTY.
I STILL KNOW THERE ARE HOSPITALS
HERE IN SOUTHEAST MICHIGAN WHO
SIMPLY DO HAVE ENOUGH EQUIPMENT
AND I HAVE SPOKEN TO TONS OF
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
IN THE ICUS AND INTEGRATING
PATIENTS EVERY DAY AND THEY ARE
USING EQUIPMENT THAT THEIR
BROTHER GOT THEM OR SOME AMONG
THEM.
SO I DON’T THINK IT’S EASY TO
SAY THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEEDED.
BUT IT’S A BIT OF A WILD WEST
SCENARIO PARTICULARLY BECAUSE SO
MUCH OF OUR SUPPLY CHAIN ON
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND MEDICAL
GEAR, WE NOW KNOW REALLY COMES
FROM CHINA.
IT’S BEEN A REALLY DIFFICULT
EXPERIENCE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF GETTING HOLD OF THE
GUY WHO HAS RELATIONSHIPS IN
CHINA WITH A FACTORY, PLACES
THAT ORDER, OR DELAYS IN THE
CUSTOMS, THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
GETTING INVOLVED WITH THE
MIDDLEMAN.
THAT’S BEEN LIKE A WILD WEST.
>> Ed: ON THAT LAST POINT,
SINCE DAY ONE OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION, AND I KNOW YOU
DON’T AGREE WITH THEM ON A LOT.
BUT IS THIS SOMETHING THAT WHEN
THIS PANDEMIC IS THROUGH AND WE
FEEL LIKE WE FINALLY HAVE OUR
ARMS AROUND IT, DO YOU THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING BOTH PARTIES
CAN WORK ON AND SAY THIS SUPPLY
CHAIN, THE STRANGLEHOLD BY CHINA
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE FOR AMERICA?
>> YES I DO.
I JUST INTRODUCED A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION CALLED THE MADE IN
AMERICA SUPPLY CHAIN INITIATIVE.
IT WON’T HELP US TODAY BUT THE
GOAL IS THAT WE WILL NEVER AGAIN
BE HAMSTRUNG BY ALL OF OUR
SUPPLIES COME FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES WHEN IT’S REALLY SO
IMPORTANT FOR CERTAIN ITEMS.
I THINK THIS IS AN AREA THAT
OVERLAPS.
I WANTED TO BE BIPARTISAN, BUT I
DON’T THINK ANYONE WANTS TO BE
BEHOLDEN.
THAT’S AMERICAN PROVISION IN THE
LAW ON MILITARY EQUIPMENT
BECAUSE WE DON’T EVER WANT TO
DEPEND ON ANOTHER COUNTRY FOR
OUR MILITARY HARDWARE.
AND, THEY ARE FLATTENING THE
CURVE, ARE YOU FLATTENING THE
CURVE THERE?
>> WE ARE IN OUR WORST TWO WEEKS
WEEKS.
WE’VE HAD MORE DEATHS PER CAPITA
THAN ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE HOPEFULLY AT THE TIP OF
OUR CURVE AND HOPEFULLY WE ARE
GOING TO COME BACK DOWN.
I DO THINK SOME OF THE
AGGRESSIVE ACTION THAT WE TOOK
IN THE STATE LED BY OUR GOVERNOR
IS FLATTENING THE CURVE.
THEY ARE IN IT RIGHT NOW AND
IT’S TRAUMATIZING FOR A LOT OF
THEM.
>> Ed: YOU JUST MENTIONED THAT
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER.
AS YOU KNOW BETTER THAN I SHE’S
FACED A LOT OF CRITICISM FOR
SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS, SAYING
MICHIGAN AREAS CANNOT GO TO
THEIR SECOND HOMES.
THESE ARE NOT RICH PEOPLE BUT
THEY ARE GOING TO A LAKE HOME OR
COTTAGE.
SOME STORES ARE BEING TOLD YOU
CAN’T SELL PAINT.
IF FOLKS ARE SAYING HOW DO
STOPPING THE SAILS OF PAINT, HOW
DOES THAT HELP YOU WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS.
HAS SOME OF THIS GONE TOO FAR?
>> I THINK THERE WILL BE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALIVE IN A FEW MONTHS
BECAUSE OF THE AGGRESSIVE
ACTIONS THAT ARE GOVERNOR TOOK.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE MODERN
COMIC MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKING.
ANY CRISIS AND OF LEADERSHIP
WILL DRAW CRITICISM.
NO ONE LIKES THAT WE CAN’T GO UP
NORTH IN MICHIGAN, EVERYBODY
GOES UP NORTH.
NO ONE LIKES THAT WE CAN’T GO TO
OUR LAWN AND GARDEN STORE IS.
BUT WE DIDN’T DO THAT IN AN
ARBITRARY WAY.
BUT IF YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE THE
VIRUS WE DON’T WANT TO SPREAD IT
TO THE COMMUNITY UP FOR MIKE
NORTH.
IT’S NOT THAT WE DON’T WANT
PEOPLE BUYING PAINT BUT IT’S A
PLACE THEY CONGREGATE AND BUY
PAINT ALLOWS FOR MORE
TRANSMISSION.
WE ALL WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK
AND THAT’S EVERYTHING WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE TO LET THE MEDICAL PIECE
GUIDE US BECAUSE THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO, CAN YOU IMAGINE IF WE
GET BACK TO WORK AND SUDDENLY
THE VIRUS SPREADS AGAIN AND WE
HAVE A SECOND WAVE?
WE HAVE TO KILL THIS THING IS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
I KNOW SHE’S TAKEN SOME HITS AND
SHE’S BEEN AN EASY TARGET, BUT I
THINK IF YOU ARE TAKING
AGGRESSIVE ACTION YOU SHOULD BE
REWARDED.
>> Ed: YOU MENTIONED YOU
WORKED AT THE PENTAGON AND WERE
A CIA ANALYST AS WELL.
THERE ARE PROTESTERS NOW IN YOUR
STATE SAYING THE GOVERNOR HAS
VIOLATED THE CONSTITUTION IN
THEIR EYES AND GONE AFTER SOME
OF THEIR FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOM.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THAT’S THE RIGHT TO PROTEST.
I HOPE THEY STAY IN THEIR CARS
AND DON’T CONGREGATE BUT LISTEN.
LIKE EVERY OTHER GOVERNOR, THE
GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN ACTION BASED
ON THE AUTHORITY THAT SHE HAS
JUST LIKE IN NEW YORK OR
LOUISIANA OR ANY OTHER PLACE.
IT DOESN’T VIOLATE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO BE
FORWARD THINKING ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THINK ABOUT THE HUMAN BEINGS WE
ARE TRYING TO HELP HERE.
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE WHO GET SICK
BUT THOSE WORKING ON THE FRONT
LINES OF AMERICA’S LATEST WORK,
IN THE HEALTH CARE COMMUNITIES
AND IN THE HOSPITAL.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THOSE
HOSPITALS ARE NOT OVERRUN AND
SUPPORT OUR FRONT-LINE WORKERS.
>> Ed: WE’VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT LAWMAKERS AND IS TRYING TO
GET THEM WHAT THEY NEED.